[Funny Music]
Lady voice: not enough to attract players to install the game
But must also
Keep the players hesitant on the game
Until the game becomes successful.
We offer you ten useful ways to do this.
When you add a Google login to your games,
There will be great new opportunities to interact with players,
This reduces the burden of sign-in
Because the user will not have to go through a setup process
new account.
With Google Play's gaming services achievements,
You can create a series of tasks
Which players can implement within the game
As well as tell users when these tasks are completed.
Achievements may be one goal
Or things that players do several times.
You can also hide achievements to prevent any unwanted interventions.
Usually the most active players are enthusiastic
To achieve all the achievements of the game,
Especially if they have a challenging or confidential nature
Or humor.
Players like to measure their skills compared to others' skills
This is what panels do in the lead.
You can create up to 70 panels in the foreground
Through Google Play game services.
View boards in the foreground daily, weekly or always
In tracking the results of the players
So that they can compare their results with friends' results
Or the public.
By providing saved games through Google Play Games services,
You can attract players to continue where they left off
Between different sessions, and allows them to change devices
And continue playing between your smartphone and tablet
And Android TV.
What attracts the most players
Enter the challenge to defeat other players.
With Google Play game services,
You can easily add multiple players
To real-time games and role-playing games.
Through the Nearby Appliance API,
Players can join their friends in one room,
On different devices.
You can add tasks to display time challenges within the game
Players can complete them for bonuses.
You can assign tasks without updating your app
For specific dates and rewarding players who complete them
Using elements within the game.
Statistics help players provide information
About the behavior of players in the game.
You'll get detailed earnings statistics,
Data retention players,
Player progress level data, and much more.
You can also set and track profitability goals
To assess the level of physical success of the game.
These statistics help you improve your game
And make it more attractive to users.
Shows you the flows in players' statistics on
Play Games How much players advance in the game
And determine where to withdraw.
The level may be difficult and can not be overcome.
It may be difficult to access an advantage within the game.
This allows you to identify the features that players are playing
Access it a lot.
You can take advantage of this information to improve and update your game.
Using AdMob and Google Analytics,
You can target ads to different categories of users
To be more relevant,
This gives users a better experience.
For example, you can target users
Make purchases from your game already
By announcing the promotion of another product within the game,
Targeting users who have never purchased
Anything with regular ads.
The appearance of the game and how it works
An important element for you and the players,
So be sure to have that look in your ads as well.
With embedded ads, you can customize your ads
And improve interaction with your AdMob campaigns
To experience the game.
Learn more about attracting players
Increase game use ratio,
You can go to the distribution section
In the Android app developer site.
And if you want to get more tips on how to improve performance
Or game and create a better app business
Check out other videos in this series
Download the "Google Play App Success Secrets" guide.